In a world where workplace
diversity sessions
increasingly resemble
Maoist struggle sessions,
Chloé Valdary's theory
of enchantment seminars
seek to bring people together
using popular culture,
to explore our common humanity
and to generate empathy
rather than division.
The 28 year old Valdary started a group
to combat antisemitism as an undergrad
at the University of New Orleans,
and after a fellowship at
the Wall Street Journal's opinion page,
she created Theory of
Enchantment as an alternative
to the anti-racist programs of people
like Ibram X. Kendi and Robin DiAngelo.
Valdary thinks that these programs often
deepen the very resentments
they seek to alleviate.
Her program on the other
hand employs materials
as varied as Disney's Lion
King, music by Kendrick Lamar,
and writing from James
Baldwin and Cheryl Strayed.
She spoke to reason about
how her life experiences
informed Theory of Enchantment,
why the demand for her program is growing,
and why she's optimistic about the future
of race relations and individualism.
Here is Chloé Valdary.
Chloé Valdary, thanks
for talking to Reason.
Thank you for inviting
me, Nick, I appreciate it.
So let's start with the
theory of enchantment.
Give me the capsule summary.
What's the elevator pitch
of a theory of enchantment?
So theory of enchantment is a startup.
It's my company, and we teach anti-racism
in the corporate boardroom and beyond,
and we have a very specific approach
to this particular practice
that combines popular culture,
the arts, with a kind of
mindfulness, understanding
of how to fight again and
combat prejudice and bigotry.
What's the landscape,
say in like corporations and offices?
I mean, is racism
afoot?
I mean, is it like a wildfire?
Is it a muted, you know, smoldering?
Is it, you know,
how bad is the problem that
you're kind of talking about?
Yeah, this is actually a
challenging question for me,
because
on one level,
it's not as if companies
are being bombarded with,
you know, the spirit of Jim Crow, right.
That's not what we're talking about here,
and to that point, as I'm sure you know,
there's been a giant proliferation of
diversity and inclusion programs
over the past year and a half due to
some of the events of last year.
So you would think, or one would assume,
that because of that proliferation,
there's actually not much
prejudice in the workplace.
There's not much bias in the workplace,
but the problem is that
because a lot of the trainings
that exist, because a lot of the trainings
that are super popular
today are in some ways
creating
results that end up
promoting prejudice,
you have this by-product effect where
people are actually being
inundated with a kind of approach
to anti-racism that creates
the likelihood of more
prejudice, not less.
So that's like people like
Ibram Kendi or Robin DiAngelo
are probably the two best
known kind of mascots
for this approach where, you know,
everything, every situation is actually
fraught with a massive amount of
unacknowledged racism and the job of
the kind of facilitators
to come in, you know,
and in Robin DiAngelo's
new book Nice Racism
it's like to come into, you
know, like NPR headquarters.
I'd love to see her come in
and, you know, and just be like,
you know, you guys are the worst
because you don't
acknowledge you're racist,
but you're saying that's
part of the problem
that your program is trying to
kind of work around or get past.
Yes, because it's based
upon a couple of things
that are problematic,
a couple of ideas that are problematic.
If you believe that
anything and everything
is white supremacy, for
example, as it seems to me,
especially individuals like
Robin DiAngelo believe,
then you are sort of
ironically actually claiming
that white supremacy is this all powerful,
all pervasive thing.
You're actually accepting a premise
that white supremacists profess,
and in doing so you sort
of perpetuate this belief
or this stereotype that people of color
are helpless victims and will
always be helpless victims,
and that creates a caricaturing
of both black and white people,
which actually just leads to
more prejudice in the workplace
as opposed to getting rid of it,
and then, you know, the second
thing I'd say that that does
is that that has a cultural
effect in the long run,
because people are
essentially asking themselves,
or saying to themselves, I
want to be a good person,
I want to do the right thing,
this is super in vogue,
and this is what I'm being
told makes me a good person,
so it just metastasizes
and it has more giant effect
than it would otherwise,
perhaps in a, you know,
in a non-digital age.
So let's say, you know,
I run a corporation
and, you know, I want to
bring in you in order to
kind of facilitate
better relationships across
my corporation or whatever.
How do you proceed?